so Richard I can't help but notice and
admire your tie which has penguins on it
is there a significance to that of
biological significance I mean these are
chinstrap penguins it's hand-painted by
my wife Lila well really as all my ties
are she paints ties so this is a one-off
type of nothing else like it in the
world it's fabulous
we went to Antarctica last Christmas on
a cruise and we spent Christmas on the
boat in Antarctica so this was my
Christmas present because we were seeing
millions of penguins and this is a
wonderful present to have do you have a
particular interest in penguins or as
you know I love penguins I mean their
astonishing animals the way they fly
underwater they look so clumsy on land
my clumsy little humans waddling along
then they get underwater and they're
phenomenally fast you wouldn't believe
how quickly they can so they can swim
through the water the streamlining is
beautiful and so like like dolphins
they're astonishingly fast and they do
darkening out of the water they they
jump out of the water and then back in
again and a lovely dolphin right way you
your first big success was The Selfish
Gene book called The Selfish Gene and
then you wrote The God Delusion
which made you a rather controversial
figure but also along with Christopher
Hitchens and Sam Harris and Daniel
Dennett really made the word atheist
acceptable and I think before that
people were ashamed to say they were in
a theatre embarrassed or I mean and as
you have pointed out before you can't
run for office in this country yes if
you're an atheist if you say you don't
you're not a believer but I know that
you you're your autobiography which this
is part one of two parts an appetite for
wonder you hardly mention religion in
that why is that well I give me a fetid
would run for its money in The God
Delusion the I've written about ten
books between The Selfish Gene under God
Delusion
and all of them about science
but the science that they're about is
pretty much implies atheism so it's kind
of implied in them in them this book is
about my early life childhood school
days university life early research
career and so I suppose I just wanted to
tell the story of my life in case
anybody's interested and there is a
story of how I lost religious faith in
there but it doesn't dominate the book
nor should it do you find I know
wherever you go and there are crowds and
qat and people always want to ask you
questions about religion and the
universe and why are we here in the
meaning of life do you are you tired of
bad are you tired because those
questions are so important and and
something you said just now about sort
of making atheism respectable not quite
sure that we did that exactly but what I
think we did do and people tell me in
the book signing cues which which very
gratifying they tell me that The God
Delusion
gaze of the courage to come out as
atheist they in some cases have actually
converted them but in rather more cases
they already were atheist and it gave
them the courage to come out which
suggests to me that there are a hell of
a lot more atheists in this country than
anybody realizes and I think there may
be a certain Emperor's New Clothes
effect that that nobody actually speaks
out and says that they're an atheist and
yet if enough of them did suddenly they
all would we get a kind of tipping point
affect you we're talking about members
of Congress and how out of all the 535
members of Congress there's only one
person who claims to not be a believer
do you believe that statistically it
can't be true it they've got to be at
least at least 100 probably 200 members
of Congress who are not religious
believers if you just look statistically
at that term the rest of the population
especially the educated population which
many of them are so they've got to be
many many many Congress people who are
all are a theist but they they just
don't want to talk about it because they
think it'll lose
those and once again I wonder whether
that an emperor's new clothes effect and
whether that actually if some of them
hide it they might be quite surprised
that they wouldn't lose those they might
even gain loads when you were on the
Capitol Hill yesterday with Steven
Pinker and you met with a number of
Senate staffers and then House staffers
who came to listen to you all talk about
secularism what why did they come what
was that about well we said I didn't ask
them why they came but they did come in
in quite substantial numbers and they
are very interesting questions and they
seem very enthusiastic they we both
talked one after the other it was a very
good meeting it was it had a sort of
feel of a good atmosphere a good
enthusiastic atmosphere were there the
kind of questions that you normally get
on your tour or were they more pointed
were they political I mean do you think
that they're trying to sort of figure
out can we really do this can I really I
wish they were I didn't get the feeling
that they're exactly doing that but I
think that they were interested in the
issues that we should be raised for
example the question of creationism in
this country it is an astonishing
shocking fact that delivered more than
40% of the vehicle opposed to be
believed more than 40% of the people in
this country leaves of the the world is
less than 10,000 years old which is not
just wrong is it's prodigiously wrong
for the true age of the earth is 4.6
billion years and 10,000 it's a tiny
tiny fraction as I said before it's
equivalent to believing that the width
of North America is 80 arms that's
that's the scale of the error and yet
40% of the American people believe it
and textbooks in Texas are tailored to
to cope with this extraordinary opinion
of ignorant people you know I at the
Press Club where you were speaking I
sort of felt as though I were in the
presence of the Dalai Lama or
hope of atheism you do have this
incredible following I mean people were
getting up and almost weeping and saying
you saved my life and I was going to
become a nun until I read your books of
God Delusion yeah I mean well yes I mean
I was both moved and slightly
embarrassed
I loved that actually but I did that
anymore I mean took two of them in quick
succession did that yeah anymore one
thought it was a bit like sort of Billy
Graham meeting with me that's right it
did it was reminiscent because I've seen
so many religious leaders where people
get up and say you saved my life yes you
know weeping and you know kissing
there's your penguin tied about it but
nevertheless it is moving and it's it's
the reaction that I get I'm a little bit
more subdued than that because there's
the reaction I often get well a majority
of the people in my book signing cues
say something similar to that which is
really very gratifying well I mean you
can imagine does it go to your head
[Laughter]
where you started out you said there was
very little that you were talking about
about religion in your book but can you
tell me I think you said you actually
were quite religious when you were about
13 you became confirmed and you got into
religion in a big way and then when you
were about 17 or 18 you became
militantly anti religion tell me about
that but with other science that this is
not unusual for a child to be religious
I mean my parents actually weren't but
but nevertheless my schools were and I
was confirmed and everybody at the
school was confirmed I think there was
one boy who was a Roman Catholic family
and he wasn't cut he was confirmed into
the Roman Catholic Church but all all
the rest of us were automatically
confirmed to the Anglican Church so it
wasn't a big decision on my part I just
kind of went a went with the flow and
then was pretty religious until the age
of about 15 and then and then gave it up
when I found that the
the Darwinian alternative which really
works as an explanation for the apparent
design of living things I was as a
biologist I was very impressed with the
apparent design of living things they
look designed I mean no penguins look
beautifully designed for swimming very
fast through the water they're not
designed they've evolved by natural
selection and it took me until I was
about 16 to really understand that
properly and then I gave up all
semblance of religion you know it's when
talking about sort of being the Dalai
Lama or the Pope of atheism
I get the sense when I see you around
other people that they're coming to you
hoping to find the answers and you know
and of course you have talked about how
one of the things that guides you most
is that what the existence of humans why
are we here was what's the meaning of
life do you ever feel somehow inadequate
that you can't provide the answers
they're looking for because it does have
it there is a certain messianic feeling
about it you know the people will go to
the Dalai Lama I went to hear the Dalai
Lama and I didn't understand a word he
said but people were weeping and you
know getting down on their knees and you
know and so I it I don't mean to make it
sound like yeah but but do you ever feel
that somehow you should have the answers
and you don't have the answers these are
not my answers I mean I've been haven't
forbid that I should be treated in this
way I mean about my answers these are
the answers of science and I'm I can try
to express the answers of science the
questions we're talking about these are
the deep questions why are we here what
are we for when did life start why did
it start all those sorts of questions
they're not my answers these these are
the answers of standard science and and
I've done my bit to try to to explain
them in really all all my books and so I
try to do that but ever the bad I'm not
a messianic need or anything like that I
one of my favorite - bumper stickers I
once saw was I don't know it you don't
either
and I I thought in a way you know you I
guess you call yourself an atheist what
does that mean to you well I don't know
you don't either I thoroughly approve of
that especially if we just say you don't
either you're a religious person because
the the great fallacy is to say science
doesn't know therefore religion must be
right and that of course is a total
logical fallacy there are plenty of
things that we don't know there are
things that science doesn't know but if
science doesn't know something that's
absolutely no reason to think that
religion does know it we must have order
to the trap of thinking there's a kind
of religious default which we default to
when science can't provide the answer
science is working on the answer silence
in some cases may never get the answer
but as absolutely no reason to think
that therefore we default to the
religious arts are certainly not you you
talk about various different labels
there's atheists there's AD Gnostic
there pantheist there Deus how do you
define the difference in those and and
what what works for you okay
well deism is is as you know the the
belief that no particular personal God
but just some kind of creative
intelligence which set the whole clock
running set the universe going and then
[ __ ] and did nothing more
so doesn't forgive sins doesn't listen
to prayers doesn't know what we think
has no interest in human affairs just
started the laws of physics going that's
deism theism is believe in some kind of
personal God such as the Christian God
the Muslim God and the gods of Valhalla
venero Olympians on pantheism I
characterized a sexed-up atheism it's
sort of kind of what Einstein believed
he died he'd nine Stein did not believe
in any kind of personal God but he had a
kind of reverence for that which we
don't yet understand and some pantheous
would feel there was a kind of
I don't know it's hard to quite
characterize exactly what what what
pantheists believe agnostics are people
who don't know that word was coined by
thomas henry huxley Darwin's friend and
colleague some people confuse that
Gnosticism with thinking there's a kind
of 50/50 toss-up whether there's a God
or not and there's really no reason to
come for 50/50 in a sense we're all
agnostic because we can never actually
disprove we can't disprove leprechauns
and Pixies and we have to be agnostic
about them but for all practical
purposes we are a leprechaun us and a
pixie in the same way we can be we can
be a theist while technically admitting
that we cannot actually disprove the
existence of any particular God so why
wouldn't you call yourself as an
agnostic then well I do sometimes call
myself an agnostic but I but I'm a bit
wary of that because people sometimes
think that means a total non commitment
and I'd rather say that I'm an atheist
in the same sense as I'm an a to fairies
mm-hmm do you has your view changed of
religion since you wrote The God
Delusion
no you and and you seem at at least when
the book came out it seemed to me that
you were much more militantly
atheist than you are now I mean you you
seem to be have pulled back a little bit
Hempel back now actually you might be if
you reread The God Delusion you might be
quite surprised actually I think it's a
bit of a myth that it's a militant book
it's been assiduously criticized as a
militant book and it's been called
aggressive and inscribed and and shrill
and things like that I think if you read
it again you might be no concept we know
I've actually had people say that to me
that they that they thought it was going
to be a militant book because they read
critics of it and then I mean one woman
told me that she thought she better
they get around to read it because she'd
heard it was such a militant strident
thrill aggressive book and she couldn't
believe it was the same book because it
was actually quite a gentle book and the
the my latest book the the Abbott an
appetite for wonder is a gentle book too
so I don't think I'd pull back mind if
this is not about religion but I hope
this is an extremely gentle book I found
anyway it's very cozy it's not because
it's not because they but no but it was
it was very thoughtful and and it's it
it sort of belies the impression that
some people have of you that you're this
sort of radical fundamentalist we are
Yeller I didn't I don't shout no no
there's there's no shouting in here at
all but I when you talk about pantheism
the deism all of that you have to look
at science and you say okay well we can
sort of trace it back to the Big Bang
the creation or whatever it is and then
we don't know what happens after that
asana to people hmm so before that I
think if we can leave anything at all
right yes well exactly and then you
you've talked about nothing ism yes what
does that mean I mean how can you put
your mind around that I mean don't you
lie awake at night because you say you
don't like not understanding things and
obviously your whole life is about
trying to understand things doesn't it
make you crazy sometimes that you don't
understand it yes I mean I'm not a
physicist and and so I I mean I'm a
biologist of an evolutionary biologist
and so I I know that the human brain was
never evolved to understand the
mysteries of quantum theory for example
the human brain evolved to understand
how to hunt
antelopes on the African plains and how
to find water holes and how to find a
shelter for the night and how to find a
mate these are all practical problems
and the human brain evolved to solve
them
very surprisingly and wonderfully the
human brain turns out to be capable of
doing all sorts of other things like
poetry and music and logic and
mathematics and quantum theory not all
of us very few of us can do it but there
are physicists who can cope with this
these profundities these difficulties of
modern physics it isn't easily
compatible with common sense the big
value means well the Big Bang and the
statement that physicists make the time
and space began at the Big Bang there is
no meaning to the word before
well I can't comprehend that I don't
think you can know but that's no not the
number one finger in the world that's
that's no reason to that's no reason to
retreat from it because if you could do
physics by common sense we wouldn't need
physicists I mean there are difficulties
here which common sense can't cope with
and some physicists say that they're
when they actually try to understand it
with their own subjective intuitive
feelings they can't either they can do
the mathematics and it works Lawrence
Krauss my colleague we've did a film
together called the unbelievers and he's
written a book called a universe from
nothing and he produced his physical
physical Theory mathematically worked
out to show that you can get something
from nothing that not that nothing and
nothing some in some strange way
canceled canceled itself out to produce
something and quantum theory allows that
to happen
well I'm humble enough to say I don't
understand it and I'm not arrogant
enough to say because I don't understand
it therefore it can't be right as I said
before if we could do physics by common
sense we wouldn't need physicists
so what's hard to understand is if there
is this creation and there was a creator
or something
it was created it then who created them
what created the creator and and what
they're saying is nothing there was no
yes there was no need to talk about it
Korea that's just too hard to understand
yes it is it's doing it's too hard to
understand at a cognitive level as
ordinary human common sense beings but
the physical theory is they're not all
physicists except that they have a
different theory but I think we have to
admit that we're not all capable of
grasping everything that the human mind
has managed to grasp and I'm excited to
be in the company of physicists who do
understand it it was always clear to me
that the origin of all things had to be
very simple because it's a lot easier to
get something from something from to get
complexity from simplicity by I mean I'm
an evolutionist and that's what
evolution does you can start with
simplicity I wasn't quite prepared to
start with absolutely nothing but I sort
of imagined that that thing started with
with with great simplicity well now I'm
told by physicist you can start with
absolutely nothing mind you it's a
little bit exactly what you mean by
nothing is up the dispute no I really
can't do that I can tell you you
obviously you live and work in an
atmosphere of academia and so you know a
lot of very smart people and yeah some
of them are religious how many now well
most scientists are not yes I don't know
what percentage maybe 10% or 5% compared
to tell you how you met them how you
measure it if you take all scientists
working in the United States polls
suggest about 40% are religious if you
take the elite scientists of the United
States or members of the National
Academy of Sciences they've been elected
as distinguished scientists then it's
about 10%
our religious but if you actually Nisa
scientist who claims to be religious and
you ask what they really believe it's
quite likely to turn out to be some sort
of pantheism probably in many case in
some cases it really is a personal God
it really is the Christian God Allah or
the Jewish God but quite often it is
actually a pantheistic sort of
einsteinium religion which is not really
what I would call God belief at all I
know that you've done a number of debate
and when you're when you're in a debate
with somebody who is a believer believe
in God or even believe that Jesus is the
Son of God how do you can you respect
somebody who believes that I mean do you
think that they're stupid no I don't
think I mean I always try to respect the
individual people whether or not I
respect their beliefs and in the case of
sort of bishops when people who are who
work of a Christian but have sensible
views of science then I can even respect
their but their beliefs I can't respect
the beliefs of young earth creationists
I mean I could have to regard them as
either ignorant or stupid but I hope I
treat them with with with politeness
Johann Hari British journalist said a
rather nice thing he said I respect you
as a person too much to respect your
ridiculous beliefs is that rather nicely
I think so yes because your book is
called an appetite for wonder and also
wonder often is what people who are
religious or believers talk about the
transcendent the wonder of the universe
the wonder of God all of that can you
separate those out of course yes I think
any good scientist is filled with Wonder
Einstein said it Carl Sagan said it
great scientists always filled with
Wonder did they they rely on their
imagination Einstein said imagination is
more important than knowledge so wonder
yes and I think that scientists have
probably a better handle on
wonder than van theologians mean we are
aware of the sheer wonder of the fact
that the universe is gigantic the time
is gigantic that life was produced by
explicable phenomena working over a very
very long time working on very simple
beginnings just the laws of chemistry
just molecules interacting with each
other and by this astonishing process
called evolution by Darwinian natural
selection produced ever increasing
complexity of living creatures including
ourselves including our brains which are
so complex and so large that they
finally become capable of understanding
the very process that gave rise to them
in that is a wonderful thought and who
in any sphere who among theologians
could possibly match that for a
wonderful exhilarating thought let's
talk about the sneeze right so you say
that if Hitler's father had sneezed at a
certain time Hitler may not have been
conceived
if would you explain what yes I mean I
wanted to make the point that we that
our existence every one of our
existences hangs by a thread or quite
astonishing luck and so I chose Hitler
because if Hitler hadn't lived then the
whole history of the 20th century would
have would have been different
hips of fathers his name wasn't Hitler
was schicklgruber yeah
Kyle schicklgruber if hair schickel
Gruber had not secretly I caught a don't
know Eggman when he sneezed what I'm
saying is that a sneeze 20 years before
Hitler was born would have been enough
to change circumstances knock-on effects
such that why I mean decline why they
mainly hit Hitler came into existence
because of a particular sperm out of
million
happened to hit a particular egg at a
particular time
now all the Huxley expressed that rather
elegantly in in his poem which went a
million million spermatozoa all of them
alive out of their catechism but one
poor Noah dare hope to survive and all
that billion minus one might have chance
to be Shakespeare another Newton and you
done but the one was me shame to have
ousted your betters thus taking our call
the others remained outside better for
all of us wrote homunculus
if you quietly died well we always have
they all rain up they asked whether what
the sneeze has to do it right
never mind the sneeze I mean just the
moment of conception of any one of us a
million million spermatozoa the exact
timing of them of the act of copulation
which gave rise to each one of us would
have totally changed which of a million
million sperms hit the jackpot on that
particular occasion now a sneeze
immediately before the conception could
clearly have that effect it was simply
change the timing a sneeze 20 years
earlier would change the timing of when
her Shakur Gruber happened to get on a
bus to Berlin or or he caught this bus
rather than that MRSA means there's a
whole knock-on series of effects which
with by a route by a circuitous route
which we can't possibly reconstruct
would nevertheless have determined have
changed which of many sperms happen to
work not just in hips as Odin generation
of course in every generation that you
can think of you and me and our parents
and our grandparents and our
great-grandparents we none of us have
any right have any entitlement to be
alive yet we are with hindsight somebody
had to be alive and it happens to be
asked then i express this in the opening
sentences of another of my books on
unweaving the rainbow we are going to
die and that makes us the lucky ones
most people are never going to die
because they're never going to be born
we're astonishingly lucky to have been
born I said in another way in another
part of the book if the second dinosaur
to the left of the third of the tall
cycad tree hadn't happened to sneeze he
would have caught the little shrew like
animal at his feet which was destined to
give rise to all the mammals of all the
mammals are descended from one creature
that lived under there let's say in the
Jurassic era and that one creature that
they all descended from every single man
was descended from this one creature
could so easily have been eaten by a
dinosaur before it reproduced and I'm
speculating I'm conjecturing that
something as trivial as a sneeze by a
dinosaur saved the life of that one
level and therefore saved the life I
mean made possible the life of every
mammal including ourselves you've used
the word luck several times in the last
few minutes and luck sounds a little bit
like fate it doesn't sound very
scientific oh well the mistake is to use
luck in a sort of predictive way to say
something like certain people are lucky
you say somebody is a very lucky person
there if I mean if all you means that
they've had a lot of luck that's fine
but if you mean that they are prone to
luck if you mean you couldn't predict I
mean the most extreme example of this I
talked about is in a cricket match it's
probably the same in baseball matches
and things as well who bats first is
determined by the toss of a coin and it
may matter who bats first it certainly
does in cricket it matters a lot and
some people actually believe and the two
captains they toss a coin and one of the
captains called heads or tails some
people actually believe that some
individuals are more lucky at getting
getting the call of a toss than others
and actually may even choose a player as
captain because they think he's more
likely to win the toss so they believe
that some people are lucky people that
is total nonsense
so that's the sense in which it's
unscientific to talk about luck but it's
not unscientific to say so-and-so is
very lucky because she had a whole
series of good things happen to her by
bike by luck by chance nor is it wrong
to say that we're all lucky to be alive
because a sneeze at any time in the past
would probably have meant that we would
not be alive it still sounds like luck
to me I mean is there a lucky gene no no
but you I mean I'm talking with
hindsight yeah you could write luck with
hindsight what you mustn't do is talk
about luck with foresight or say I feel
Luck's with me tonight I feel lucky
tonight I'm going to go and play
roulette at Las Vegas because I feel
lucky tonight or I have a lucky number
or the roulette spins have come up with
red five times in a row so the luck
suggests that it ought to be what either
say it's likely to go on being read all
boards it's about timing change to black
because it's blacks tournament either of
those are so-called gamblers fallacy but
look at you I mean you're an incredibly
lucky person I mean you had a wonderful
happy childhood you had a great
education you had a fantastic career you
know you've had an amazing life and then
we look at some of the people who've
just been gassed in Syria or the people
who are starving in Africa or the people
who are being stoned for adultery
somewhere or whatever could have natural
catastrophe how do you explain that I
mean this is this is from an atheist
point of view obviously it's one of the
most obvious questions to ask a
religious person how do you explain
suffering if there's a loving God but
from an atheist point of view how to
explain that you get to have such a
fabulous life in someone else is is not
lucky to have been born so far I've been
talking about just talking about luck
with hindsight friends and so that's
that's you could say that to somebody
tosses coins and and it comes up heads
while floor dos if someone is lucky at
Roulette that's luck with hindsight
that's pure hindsight absolutely
everything to do with it if anything in
the ability it's pure hindsight when you
say somebody has had a very very
fortunate life that's not necessary
hindsight I mean you leave me out of it
but but people who are born with a
silver spoon in their mouth people who
who pool of wealthy parents have a good
education have good genes I get it get
get a good job because of their good
because of their their abilities and
they go on and they Kataria success of
their life I won't use the word luck for
that I mean I would say that this is
various things favored them their genes
their upbringing their education their
parents for that they were brought up in
a home lined with books like this studio
you don't want to attribute that to
chance to luck that's that's a set of
circumstances they were well endowed in
all sorts of of sense if that's not
mysterious well I find it mysterious I
mean I I find that so if you look at
thirds the division between rich and
poor and the people who suffer and the
people who don't it's mysterious why why
me
when I get to have a good life and
something else you know no losses all
their children and a massacre this is
because this is because you sort of feel
they ought to be some kind of natural
justice I mean you you feel you feel it
somehow wrong that somebody should
should have all this good fortune and
another's not and if there were natural
justice it wouldn't happen and and
certain societies do their best to as it
were redistribute the good fortune
countries like the Scandinavian
countries that have high tax rates and
take a lot from the rich and give to the
poor I mean things like Obamacare is
trying to do in a very very small way
this is trying to achieve a certain
amount of natural jazz of
of just as a redistributive justice and
you are protesting when you say some
people have a charmed good life and
other people end up being gassed into in
Sicilia that's of course terrible other
people are poor some are rich some of
summer' poor your your your sense of
justice rebelled against that because
you feel somehow it's wrong but it's
that it's the way things happen you can
do something about it you can say let's
reform our society in such a way that we
do redistribute the good fortune of it
but there's no natural justice the
universe doesn't owe poor people the
same living as as rich people it's just
the way things happen to turn out when
people say something like um if somebody
gets a terrible disease gets terrible
cancer and painful counts for something
says why me why did it happen to me I
didn't ever do anything wrong I'm a good
person why me it's a total fallacy to
think that because you're a good person
therefore bad things shouldn't happen to
you or you're a bad person and you have
a perfect health again no natural
justice
there isn't any natural justice that's
one of the points so you mentioned
earlier that if you have good genes so
what does that mean to have good genes
well your genes affect all sorts of
things like your health your ability to
do to do things your mental ability or
physical ability that's all natural
selections all about the choice of good
genes to survive genes that help you to
survive and in the wild all animals are
subject to natural selection which means
that the genes that make them good at
surviving because gives them good
eyesight good ears good good claws good
teeth good running limbs good wings to
fly with those are all those all
represent good genes and it's the good
genes that survive to the next
generation and then the next and then
the next so genes are very important in
endowing an individual of any species
with the ability to not just survive but
to do all sorts of other things so some
people undoubtedly will be endowed with
better genes than others people may die
because they have genetic diseases other
people were endowed with genes that make
them live
a long healthy life well one of the
things you said in the book which
fascinated me was the fact that people
that essentially we all come from the
same gene that were all genes that were
all related on some level starting at
what point and and then but then you say
that if you go three or four generations
along the person in the last generation
probably won't have very much genetics
and no that's right
same as yes person if we explain that
yes
if you want to ask the question how long
ago did we share a common ancestor the
answer is probably not very far we've
got each one of us have got two parents
four grandparents eight
great-grandparents sixteen and so on
that exponential increase in ancestors
can't go on because if it did if you if
you actually calculate how many people
they would have to have been say in the
time of William the conquerer that 1066
just from my ancestors it would be more
than the population of the world at the
time and we do the same for yours and
the same for everybody else's so
obviously we all share as ancestors if
you look at it the other other way
around you don't have to go back very
far until you reach a point where just
simply on mathematical grounds if you if
you imagine that we're all living on an
island and all reproducing a little bit
random we don't divide it into separate
groups at all living together you'd only
have to go back a few thousand years for
everybody in the world to be descended
from the same common ancestor so we're
related of course we are yes you and I
are very closely related and we probably
only have to go back a few hundred years
um have you had your DNA - I have as a
matter of throwing and what it is where
is it son well I mean it's bit of a game
so far because because not a hell of a
lot is known about what most of the
genes are
I'm doing the most interesting genes to
look at probably the mitochondrial genes
because they are one could go down the
female line only or males have them but
we get them from our mother
so the mitochondrial DNA little little
thing within the cell called
mitochondria have their own DNA they're
actually originally bacteria so I got it
from my mother from her mother my
maternal grandmother my maternal
maternal great-grandmother my maternal
maternal maternal great-great
grandmother and so on so this is a
narrow trickle of genes down one side of
the family tree whether they're or other
possible ways in which you could have
got genes so this makes mitochondrial
DNA very easy to trace because it's not
constantly being swamped by sexual
reproduction it doesn't recombine with
other genes so we know when our most
recent common ancestor in the female
line lived and she lived in Africa maybe
a couple of hundred thousand years ago
she's called mitochondrial Eve that's
rough journalistic name being given her
but people of European descent can trace
that their ancestors took back to a much
more recent female female common
ancestor it remember that that the
female female female one is only one way
of doing it there are all sorts of other
ways in which you could trace your
ancestry who those female male female
male female male male male male female
female and there are millions of other
ways in which you can create ancestry
and if you do it that way you and I will
turn out to be a common will happen you
and I will turn out to have a common
ancestor much much more recently than
then mitochondrial Eve Farah we're all
cousins were all relatively close
cousins go back a bit further and we're
all cousins of monkeys and chimpanzees
and kangaroos and wombats and gin and
jellyfish have you ever done
ancestry.com
have you ever true ancestry no I don't
think I have but it but you can do that
I mean it's using either y chromosome
which is the male equivalent that goes
down the male line and
females don't have that but you can do
it by getting your father or your
brother so either by the y-chromosome
DNA or mitochondrial DNA enables you to
find where your mitochondria and your
and your Y chromosome comes from it
doesn't tell you where the rest of your
genes come from I mean there was a
television program on British television
which rather foolishly I think took
people and traced their mitochondria
they took actually people descendants of
slaves from Jamaica and they had one
woman who traced her mitochondria back
to a particular tribe in West Africa
which was nice I mean quite an
interesting thing to do and they then
took her to this pride in West Africa
and we're grateful with all my people my
it nonsense - only the mitochondria and
the rest of her genes could have come
from absolutely anywhere probably came
from Russia and all sorts of places
mm-hmm that so it doesn't make it we be
to thank generally no weeping it's sort
of interesting because I'm out there but
but the perhaps them the more we pay
messages we are all cousins were all
fairly close cousins we are closely
related to each other you invented the
word meme which is now very much a part
of the language and I think you said
some 30 books have been written with the
word it is a name and I think is true
what does name mean and how did you come
to conceive about it's the unit of
cultural inheritance and I think of it
as the cultural equivalent of the gene
the reason I wanted to corn the word was
that it came at the end of my first book
The Selfish Gene and the rest of the
book is all about DNA being the unit of
natural selection so I said a moment ago
the genes that are successful are the
ones that survive through through gene
pools and so the whole effort of writing
The Selfish Gene was to emphasize the
gene as the unit of selection that which
we
benefits from an animal's behavior for
example a survival of the genes is what
animal behavior is all about but I
wanted to not leave the reader with the
impression that genes are everything I
wants to leave the reader realizing that
natural selection could work on anything
which is self copying anything where
there is where information is copied
through something equivalent to
generations DNA is the most important
example but something that's imitated
from human brain to human brain a closed
fashion a way of speaking a tune he has
used the word in an in a sentence the
reverse baseball cap is a meme that has
spread from America in u.s. culture all
over the world
nearly said it came from the French word
mem which means hell you couldn't even
relate it to the French word mem I
actually got it from a Greek word my
meme mm-hmm and I could I subtracted the
initial MI and just called it meme I
wanted something that ideally should
have rhymed with gene but it doesn't
quite rhyme with genus or sort of fun
yeah but it's sort of an imitation of
some imitation imitation is the key DNA
could be said to be imitated when its
self self replicates if I sing your tune
and you get the tune in your head it's a
catchy tune you catch it and then you
garden to the street and you find
yourself whistling it you've changed the
medium from voice to whistling it
doesn't matter somebody else hears you
whistling it and they pick it up and
they sing it and somebody else here is
embracing it somebody else has done it
and they whistle it it can potentially
spread like an epidemic a crazed school
a craze for a particular toy a
particular game spreads through the
school like a measles epidemic and it
has much the same epidemiological time
course as a measles epidemic it rises
and then it dies away then it may jump
to another school because somebody knows
something brother or something sister
and that's another school so that's a
meme it's like a gene is like a virus
it's like
- so people suddenly started wearing
penguin ties exact that would be exactly
if if people saw by penguin tile less
bad i'ma have a penguin tie to your life
could get rid yes yes yeah that you'd
call is a mean if it spreads by by
imitation it wouldn't have to be exactly
the same penguin tie it can be so long
as it's recognizably inherited from from
a sequence of generations then you can
call it a mean you've got two more years
to go to finish the part two of your
memoirs what why did you decide you're
72 now right why did you decide suddenly
to write your memoirs at this point why
not another sort of scientific book well
um the publishers are a keynote I should
hmm and I just missed my father died
just before I started so I wasn't able
to consult him about past memories I was
able to consult my mother who's 96 and
that was very valuable very useful to me
it seemed a good idea to do it while I
was doing around counting down the days
very I've not ran that as for why it's
two volumes and when it was supposed to
be one volume much you signed a contract
for the whole book and then when I got
halfway through I sort of felt the need
for a bit of a sense of achievement and
and it seemed like it was actually was a
natural break point be the publication
of my first book was a sort of watershed
event in my life because my life did
rather change after that and then I
wrote a lot more books and did things
like television and radio and journalism
and things so it's a pretty natural
break point so when you finish your next
book I mean obviously that's going to
occupy your time for the next couple of
years and then the endless book tour
do you do you have a bucket list um
well there are parts of the world I
haven't yet seen and how the parts I
have Stephen would like to see again I
mean I love my only one New Zealand is
wonderful fabulous place I'd love to get
back there Australia I've seen very
little of South America I haven't seen
in China at all seen Antarctica haven't
seen the Arctic so yes I wouldn't mind
doing that I've also got other books
that I do I'd like to write as well any
novels well I don't know I've never sort
of quite known how to do that you just
make things up different but very
different from what you would do have to
do dialog I mean how do you do is that
easy
um well I've written a couple of nine oh
well I I talk a lot so I don't find it
that hard but I do quite fancy the idea
of I mean I rather like satirical novels
that a kind of close observation of the
way people talk and the way people are
some for some reason whenever I'm in
airports listening to the channel and
listening to people around me I sort of
feel I should write a novel and I sort
of you know hearing hearing the way
people talk do you read them yes Evan
else I read I like him I like modern
satirical novels I like Kingsley Amos
evylyn War Michael Frayn that that kind
of David Lodge that sort of them
perceptive would he look at that
contemporary life I like science fiction
- one of the things that I loved in your
book was you said that when you were
much younger that one of your favorite
books was gone with the wind and we read
it a number of times what was it that
very racist I mean I didn't realize when
oh well that was young but the story
itself what was it about gone with the
wind at entry I must have read it ten
time not sure I would like it now
actually I liked it as a child it
carries you along and well is LSD taking
LSD maybe
on your list well you know you did
mention in your book that someone had
recently offered to take you on a trip
and you had turned them down why did you
turn them down
well there's a chapter in my memoir
about my time in Berkeley which was the
late sixties and you might think I would
have tried it then but nobody ever
offered it to me did you ever do
marijuana no did I did nothing no
nothing never done any drugs at all
Oh later yeah and I've marijuana but but
net would never let her loose imagine
like like LSD or mescaline and recently
a friend offered to mentor me through an
LSD trip and she said she'd take a half
dose so that she was sort of empathizing
but but still capable of making sure I
didn't jump out of the window think I
could fly or something like that and I I
couldn't decide whether to do it I am I
have a cousin of my father's first
cousin who's mentioned in the book is an
expert on on such drugs and I'm a
pharmacologist as a psychiatrist indeed
he was I think who influenced Aldous
Huxley to do his famous experiment thank
you taking mescaline so I wrote and
asked him whether he would advise it he
gave very balanced opinion he said on
the whole not why because of the dangers
of a bad trip and but you know I don't I
don't know maybe you can guard against
that maybe take a lower dose or
something and guard against it or for
the visual the mbrs is right so that it
doesn't happen but it did intrigue you
the idea of it it definitely intrigues
me yes yes because I'm reading
descriptions not just Aldous Huxley's
but there is other descriptions of well
Huxley sprays the doors of perception
McLin cleansed which i think is a quote
from something else yes I mean I I I
would be very curious to try it you said
he was a psychiatrist have you ever been
to a psychiatrist
not no no no no I haven't do you how do
you feel about psychiatry or therapy
sure it's a very important
seeing fun for some people I feel
perhaps very fortunate that I don't
think I'd need it maybe I'm wrong well
yeah I'm interested in that sort of
confluence between religion and
psychiatry that so many people who well
that the psychiatrist's often plays the
role that the priest plays yes and we've
talked before about the idea of good and
evil and good genes and evil genes and
what makes a person good and what makes
them a moral person and I think
sometimes when you see a psychiatrist or
you see it talk to a priest or whatever
you you're trying to bring out the best
of yourself yeah doesn't there's a
lovely part isn't there in them
Crocodile Dundee
where Crocodile Dundee is told that just
about everybody in New York goes to a
goes to a psychiatrist and he says what
about any company mates I didn't
remember that I thought but there there
is some similarity there and I think
that I think most people if you ask them
would say that they want to be good and
moral and we've as I said we've talked
about this before but how do you define
morality and do you think that often
people will say well you can't really be
moral if you are not religious you don't
believe in a God where did we get
morality and do we have a moral gene
where do we get literature yeah there
are people who think you can't define
what you mean by morality I think we we
do define it it's about it's it's
clearly true that at any particular time
in history a particular society at least
for example modern Western society
American Western European society and so
on in the 21st century has a very
distinctive 21st century morality which
we all share whether we're religious or
not and it's a kind of consensus that we
accept
it's somewhat based on the golden rule
do is you would be done by treat others
as you would wish them to treat you when
you go buy the gold yeah yes really I
mean we all took greater or lesser
extent subscribe to the sort of feeling
that we we kind of together try to
decide what kind of society we want to
live in we want to live in the sort of
society where people don't steal where
they don't kill they don't they don't
rape they don't commit grievous bodily
harm they pay taxes we take care of the
poor the sick the elderly we live in a
society which cares for each other which
cares for other sentient beings indeed
and we can sort of work out for
ourselves that this is the kind of
society in which we wish to live I doubt
any religious belief would not wish to
live in the kind of society where people
cheat where they don't pay their taxes
where they whether they rape and steal
and kill and I suppose you could say
it's a kind of redirected selfishness
because you don't want that to happen to
you and so you want to live in a
well-ordered society which way you're
protected from that what actually counts
as a well-ordered good society varies
from century to century in the 19th
century british and presumably american
society was highly sexist you couldn't
vote women couldn't vote in america
until the 1920s nor in britain or in
most of Western Europe so we've moved on
and we've moved on as a whole society
collectively some kind of collective
zeitgeist has moved on we've abandoned
that kind of sexism which said women are
not capable of voting because they can't
think I mean a barbarous things as we
would now see it but yet in the 19th
century Thomas Henry Huxley Charles
Darwin Abraham Lincoln these men were
all enlightened for their time but they
would be regarded as extremely backward
for our time and so there is a kind of
shifting zeitgeist which clearly has
nothing to do with religion
it has to do with is complicated but but
it moves on and do you think at some
point in our lives we will not be a
religious society yes I think I do think
that it may take a while its we're
moving in the right direction
in sustaining Europe and I think also in
America actually in the number of the
number of people who profess no religion
and America has now exceeded 20% at the
5th that's quite a large percentage the
percentage that hasn't been really
recognized politically but it's there in
Europe it's much higher most of Europe I
mean of all not not Poland for example
that Britain and Scandinavia and Holland
and so on in cities and a lot of that
may actually have been because of you
and your book the God to lose it
wouldn't it be nice to think that I dare
say that myself thank you